salut à tous aujourd'hui c'est dimanche
c'est donc le jour de l'explication de
la semaine c'est le jour où je vous
apprends à bluffer vos amis comme ça
fait longtemps que vous n'êtes pas
expliquer un tour de cartes c'est ce que
je vais faire ce dimanche je vais vous
apprendre un des meilleurs tours de
cartes que je pense que vous puissiez
reprendre aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a pas de
manipulation parce que c'est
indétectable un remontable comme on dit
dans le milieu des magiciens oui un
milieu de magicien en clair c'est le
tour idéal en parlant d' idées à l'idéal
serait que je puisse le faire sur
quelqu'un pour que vous ayez la
démonstration ce qu'on appelle la démo
en fait du tour avant de vous expliquer
ça et cette technique
malheureusement j'ai pas de vidéo wii
alors forcément vous dites mais pourquoi
ils n'expliquent pas des choses qui fait
dans le mental blog habituellement et
oui c'est une très bonne question vous
avez été 2 3 la poser sur différentes
vidéos dans les commentaires pourquoi je
vous explique pas ce que je ferai dans
le mental blog ce soir technique de
mentalist ou en magie et bien simplement
parce que tout ce que je vous explique
le dimanche ce sont des choses que vous
pouvez reproduire en fait et ça c'est
l'intérêt si on y réfléchit bien ça sert
à rien de donner une ferrari à quelqu'un
qui en train de passer le code je veux
pas vous donner des trucs pour vous
donner des trucs vraiment qu'on est une
notion d'apprentissage
ensemble nous sommes en train de passer
un contrat ensemble un contrat moral
il n'y a pas de contrat mais vous voyez
ce que je veux dire la démarche c'est à
dire que ce que je vous apprends dans
l'explication du dimanche c'est quelque
chose que vous pourrez faire dans la
semaine pour bluffer les gens et ça
c'est ça c'est sûr contrat je vous le
signe ici
moyennant un petit peu de travail de
votre part que ce soit en terme de
technique ou de présentation faut
forcément que vous bossiez un petit peu
dans votre coin pour pouvoir faire
quelque chose de présentable
oh la la il serait pas en train de vous
prendre la tête le dimanche au lit car
c'est vrai je suis fatigué du col a
besoin de faire des leçons de morale on
s'en fout il ya pas de leçons de morale
j'ai juste envie de faire l'explication
du dimanche pour ce mental blog
l'idée est la suivante vous avez un jeu
de cartes complet ça c'est important il
faut qu'ils aient toutes les cartes
dedans vous le faites mélangé à d'autres
spectateurs les spectateurs mélange le
jeu une fois qu'il l'a mélangé il prend
une carte lui même il a le jeu dans les
mains yves orhant le paquet et vous vous
retournez le temps tu regarde la carte
il essaye d'en faire une belle image
mentale qui va fasse voir à tous ses
amis etc
une fois que c'est fait il avait dans sa
poche il la cache sur lui admettons vous
vous retournez vous discutez avec lui
sur le fait qu'il vous est impossible
pour le moment de connaître quelle carte
il a choisi et quelques secondes après à
peine vous vous êtes déjà en possession
de l'information de la carte qui l'a
intrigant ans après la suite du tour
elle dépend de vous sait qu'une question
de présentation c'est un peu vous qui
décidez ce que vous allez faire avec
soit vous décidez de révéler la carte
qu'il a choisi puisque vous n'en avez
connaissance et il la sort de sa poche
et bim ont vérifié ces bons fins
possibles numéro 2 vous pouvez jouer au
mentaliste vous pouvez faire votre petit
fabien olicard et faire semblant de lire
les réactions sur son visage pour dire
quelle carte il a choisi ça fonctionne
aussi ça reste de la magie soit vous
faites ça cette option numéro 2 mais en
même temps vous vous entraînez
réellement à chercher les réactions sur
son visage pour savoir quelle carte il a
choisi vous êtes déjà en possession
d'informations
donc vous pouvez voir vraiment comment
la personne réagit ça vous apprend à
connaître les réactions cette personne
elle est intéressante et enfin autre
possibilité la dernière mais qu est la
plus ouverte en termes de soupe east oui
fait remettre la carte dans le jeu vous
lui faites mélanger le jeu et vous vous
récupérez le jeu et vous pouvez révélé
la carte de la manière de votre choix
par exemple si la carte était le roi
trêve vous prenez le jeu vous allez
jusqu'au roi de trèfle vous séparer le
jeu en deux comme ceci vous reposer la
partie inférieure dessus sur le paquet
et là le roi très peu en première
position et vous pouvez faire ce que
vous voulez un petit claquement de
doigts un petit je mentalise le paquet
non mentaliser c'est moi qui dis ça buzz
formule magique quelconque est en tout
cas la carte sera sur le dessus en fait
tout est possible après puisque vous
savez quelle carte il a choisi comment
faire ça je sais que je vous soulève
tout vous expliquer la et la faim et la
finalité et les trucs possibles mais
quand je vais vous révéler en fait la
manière de procéder
je veux pas que vous soyez déçu en fait
est que vous n'alliez pas plus loin
c'est très intéressant c'est sûrement
l'une des techniques que j'ai utilisées
qui m'a le plus servi je sais pas de qui
allait cette technique si quelqu'un l'a
déjà utilisé je suppose que oui en fait
je peux pas être le seul à avoir pensé
ça enfin j'ai pas de sources à vous
donner du coût de ce côté là mais je
dois pas être le seul à avoir pensé à
faire ça attention je vais vous révéler
ce que c'est il s'agit
de compter les cas recompter 10 donc
comme c'est étonnant fabien toi on passe
notre temps à raconter ou à faire des
images dans sa tête oui c'est vrai mais
ces pratiques alors vous enfuyez pas
quand même coupé pas la vidéo tout de
suite bien il ya une méthodologie qui
est très simple pour ça dans un jeu de
cartes ya 52 cartes 26 noir et 26 rouge
13 de chaque famille avec ces
informations là on peut retrouver
rapidement la carte pour vous expliquer
vous fait la démonstration en même temps
je mélange pleinement le jeu comme ça je
ne sais pas dans quel ordre sur le cas
je prends une carte au hasard je vous la
fais pas voir parce que tu pourrais
l'avoir dans l'écran du coup je vais là
posé juste ici bonne emprise sur le
dessus l'épaule avant la pause juste là
et imaginons que ce soit le spectateur
en fait qu'ils soient derrière moi qui
vient de prendre la carte
ok donc je lui tourner le dos dès que je
lui tourner le dos je vais commencer à
passer les cartes en revue et je vais
compter toutes les noirs parce que c'est
la première qui a là je vais les compter
rapidement dans ma tête en les poussant
un coût par 3 un coup part de ça va très
vite a compté c'est à dire que si je
couche comme ça ça fait 3 2 là j'ai déjà
cinq et je passe tous après dans ma main
droite pour vite éliminé up deux là il y
en a une deux trois d'axa ça me fait dix
ans 6 3 6 2 7 5 sur 15 200 faire croire
à l'amour l'argent les deux j'en ai une
deux trois donc madame dernière dont 25
et l'âge et la 26e qui est ici donc en
passant à vitesse réelle avec un tout
petit peu d'entraînement si vous
entraîner un petit peu ça ira très vite
je peux passer les cartes à cette
vitesse là
et assez rapidement déterminé il ya
vingt-six noir s'il ya vingt-six noir ça
veut dire que c'est une rouge qui
manquent
là je vais relancer mon spectateurs
c'est à ce moment là où je vais lui dire
fais toi une belle image mentale montre
là aux autres personnes je veux vraiment
que tu puisse visualiser la carte
correctement une fois que j'ai dit ça
sur ces quelques secondes je vais
essayer de déterminer la famille cissé
du coeur ou du carreau donc je reprends
mon jeu en main je repousse les cartes
et là ma première sous du coeur donc je
compte les coeurs je cherche pas à
comprendre ça me fait 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 12
13 près ce que ça veut dire que c'est
une carte à carreaux qui manquent quand
bien même je m'arrêterai là j'aurais
quand même une précieuse information est
à dire que parmi 52 cartes
au départ je ne savais pas laquelle il
avait choisi maintenant je sais parmi
treize cartes ses plus beaux coups
tresca mais il va falloir que je m'en
retourne là un moment donné donc je me
retourne vers mon spectateurs mais du
coup je reste vers vous évidemment et là
j'ai plus qu'à déterminer en fait quelle
carte
il manque à carreaux là il ya plusieurs
méthodes plusieurs pistes possibles on
compare les fortes et les faibles moi
personnellement je préfère faire les
pères et les impairs je vous explique je
vais compter rapidement toutes les
cartes pair ou impair
si vous avez le temps ci à beaucoup de
monde qui met beaucoup de temps à faire
voir sa carte aux autres personnes que
ça parle beaucoup
tant mieux vous faites ça tant que vous
avez le dos tourné et si vous êtes
retourné vous le faites en live en lui
expliquant que j'ai aucune possibilité
de savoir quelle était sa carte
je voulais mettre ces germes en 1
saillie externe conseillers externes
c'est-à-dire en décalage tout vers le
haut en qu'elle soit père ou un père le
valais pour moi c'est une carte un père
le roi aussi parce que c'est la onzième
et le roi c'est la troisième carte et le
l'association carvin perd donc là pour
l'instant j'en ai deux y a que six
cartes père sur la trescartes évidemment
donc la journée j'en ai deux qui sont
passés 3 4 5 et 6 avec la dame qui
comptent pour 12 donc je sais que c'est
une affaire donc c'est ou l'ass ou le 3
ou le 5 ou le ced ou le 9 ou le valais
où le roi et rien que le fait de les
avoir passé je peux déjà vous dire que
c'est le 3 qui manque si j'étais pas sûr
j'essaierai juste de repasser le jeu
pour faire as
la chercheure l3 je le trouverai pas par
contre je trouve bien le 5 le 7
le valais est le roi
et le 9 évidemment ne disais pas parce
que je le voyais donc je sais que c'est
le 3-2 carbon ya ici je pense que tout
ça ça vous paraît un petit peu confus
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'on met
beaucoup de temps à le faire avec un
petit peu d'entraînement mais vraiment
pas beaucoup
vous serez le faire de plus en plus
rapidement et plus vous le ferez plus
vous serez rapide c'est ça qui est
intéressant outre avantage ça fait
encore beau c'est votre cerveau pour
avoir une capacité en fait de faire
plusieurs choses en même temps tout en
contant mentalement
vous allez même réussir à terme a parlé
tout en contant vous en fais une autre
petite démonstration très rapide pour
vous voyez le temps que safran on met
une carte ici on la regarde pas et là je
vous parle plus pour pour vous voyez
vraiment la vitesse reste je m'en
retourne du spectateur je compte les
cartes jeux le comté avec vous comme ça
vous le verrez
c'est une noire qui manquent ok on fait
le retour
c'est du pic et comme j'ai l'habitude
j'ai déjà commencé à repérer les pics je
suis allé un petit peu vite mais je
pense que c'est l'as de pique et c'est
l'as de pique hockey en plus content moi
je suis toujours content dont j'ai
réussi quelque chose dans la vie en
général je suis content voilà j'espère
que ça va vous donner envie de
travailler ça parce que c'est pas une
grande technique c'est une technique
plus mental que de dextérité de
manipulation mais rappelez-vous ce que
je vous disais au début de la vidéo
c'est à vous ouvre plein de pistes de
finalité ça vous permet de toujours prêt
en fait avec un tour la seule contrainte
il faut que le jeu est bien ses 52
cartes ça c'est important
oui parce que sinon ça va vous induire
en erreur forcément j'espère que cette
explication du dimanche vous a plu et
que vous allez pouvoir le travail et
pour bluffer des gens peut-être dès
cette semaine
entraînez-vous toute manière il n'y a
pas de secret pour que ça rentre et il
faut s'entraîner merci d'être toujours
de plus en plus nombreux à regarder ce
mental blog voilà ça me fait plaisir bah
oui évidemment je vois les vues qui
montre le nombre d'abonnés qui monte ça
veut dire que vous êtes prévenus des
chaînes ça veut dire vous marquez un
intérêt ça veut dire aussi que ça aide à
faire connaître la chaîne
j'ai de plus en plus d'abonnés tous les
jours ça c'est grâce à vos partages vous
partager les vidéos pas forcément plus
il ya de gens qui découvrent la chaîne
continue et c'est tout ce que j'ai à
vous dire c'est super chouette vous
pouvez d'ailleurs vous abonner en
cliquant juste là aussi un dans chaque
vidéo il ya le petit look ok là vous
pouvez venir me voir sur scène en
spectacle pour vous faire mentaliser
pour de vrai ce durant les
hallucinations collectives la prochaine
celle 28 mars soit dans mon spectacle
fabien olicard vous mentent alyzia
toutes les dates de tournée sur le site
favori car point fr les prochaines dates
c'est à mulhouse à l'entrepôt théâtre si
vous venez on prendra le temps de faire
une vidéo à la fin pas pour le mental
blog en fait comme vous en avez déjà vu
en attendant merci beaucoup merci pour
les like les petits poussant les
remercie pour les commentaires je les
lis j'y réponds je prends tellement de
plaisir avec vous et grâce à vous voilà
je suis dans ma phase de mercy en fait
voilà merci merci merci passer un
excellent dimanche et rendez vous demain
lundi pour le prochain mentale blog ciao